[Music]
hey what's up Wolfgang not sure if
anybody caught the featurette that was
shown yesterday about ant-man and the
loss but if you did you know that Kevin
Feige had some words to say about
ant-man and the loss about Avengers for
now just a heads up about some spoilers
if you haven't seen Avengers infinity
war yet one what the heck are you doing
go see it it's been too long and two
there are some spoilers coming up
so since Avengers infinity war came out
and we saw fan OSes infamous snap where
he wiped out half the universe from
existence there's been a lot of
speculation in theories around ant-man
and the wasps regarding what role
they'll play into leading up to Avengers
4 well in the last featurette that we
got of ant-man on the wasp president of
Marvel Kevin Feige
told us just how important ant-man on
the wasp will be leading up to and in
Avengers 4 the stakes are so high we
don't have much time
and man wasp also connects directly to
Avengers for these characters are going
to be very important going forward
teaming up
so there you have it president of Marvel
Kevin Feige came out and told us that
ant-man and the wasp connect directly to
Avengers 4 he also says that these
characters are going to be very
important going forward now when he says
these characters he's not just talking
about ant-man and the wasp he's also
talking about dr. Henry Hank Pym the
reason I include him is because I think
everybody pretty much knows by now that
Avengers 4 is going to be some sort of
time-travel slash alternate reality
movie and we've all speculated for a
really long time now that the way
they're going to do this is through the
quantum realm and we do know that this
movie ant-man and the wasp will heavily
focus on the quantum realm and not to
mention that a while ago we saw these
leaked photos on a set of Avengers 4
where some of the Avengers were wearing
these weird devices on their hands but
some people did pick up on the fact that
while Captain America and Iron Man were
wearing these devices with sort of a
bracelet holding them onto their hands
ant-man actually had this device
embedded in his suit so that's where the
speculation began when we saw these
leaked photos but now it's pretty much
confirmed Kevin Feige just told us how
important not only the movie but the
characters will be leading up to and in
Avengers 4 and this is because the
quantum realm technology is going to
allow them to travel through time or
different alternate realities so they
can collect the Infinity stones before
Thanos does or they can collect Infinity
stones on their own to fight against
Stannis's Infinity Gauntlet
either way this movie is going to tell
us a lot about Avengers 4 most likely in
the post-credits scene so if you weren't
excited to see ant-man on the wasp I
hope you are now because it's leading
right into Avengers 4 the only movie
coming out after ant-man on the wasp is
Captain Marvel which is also said to
explore the quantum realm so it's going
to be a very important movie in the MCU
leading up to Avengers 4 and I'm super
excited about it and we now have less
than two weeks until it comes out let me
know your thoughts on ant-man and the
wasp and more specifically let me know
what you think we'll see in the
post-credit scenes for ant-man and the
wasp
hit that like button before you leave
and be sure to subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on ant-man and the
wasp Avengers
or all things Marvel DC and superhero
thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]